you guys holding on
[Laughter]
[Music]
now let's go do a quick play since I'm
gonna go sleep soon no cuz you'll be
like no heavy and you only got me with
Rockets I'll do let's just go well they
[ __ ] quickly
Pikachu's getting all mad cuz he knows
he was at the bottom don't be all mad
peaks it happens it looks [ __ ] black
that's no Pikachu is better than no
that's fine no happy it could be it's
not heavy
and I really want P to win just for what
let's go Peaks something that's got me
now that's a yes the map with the yellow
[ __ ] on it on the walls where's the
yellow [ __ ] javelin floors oh hey you
should just go to one of you should just
go - Pikachu steam just it just so it's
and it's bounced in case somebody gets
shot
[Music]
10 kills 10 killing no no heavy that's
fine let's go
no man I might lose actually yeah you
gotta win Pikachu prove you're the best
I remember we played last time and
you're at the house and you lost to me
and coke that was fun oh yeah he was the
worst I am the worst at all good I want
to say that will [ __ ]
I didn't well I was a game [ __ ] you
[Music]
don't be mad dude mm-hmm-hmm talk this
whole he's not gonna talk this whole
time cuz he know he's gonna be like
putting his his all and it's gonna be so
calm so should I hand cannon are the
nature of the beaches you should use the
cook took up his headset so he can comb
his long mane whatever Robbie
[Music]
I'm also in the middle
[Music]
ah what did i zoom in are using
vigilance wink you [ __ ] [ __ ] I
thought you were gonna use a hand cannon
that's my secondary bro all right let's
do what you wanna do also if you guys
are moving around [ __ ] up our radar
so please don't I'm just sitting in the
middle but if you shoot me I'll kill you
yeah but that kind of [ __ ] up the radar
to be honest yes he's coming by you yeah
but that's not cool for me cuz cokes in
the back now I think about it you'd have
to go all the way back you should be on
the back corner of the map well then I'm
gonna quit out cuz it [ __ ] on my radar
dude
alright later guys
good game no dude you're [ __ ] on my
game let's play it let's switch it you
and coke play and I'll sit in the middle
see how it is to play coke this
[ __ ] alright well good game guys
no great nom no I'm out dudes
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] I can't say
I'll cross
actually that would be more fair you
guys just meet in the middle on guitar
more than on fire
I think agent Somali intense yeah I just
wanted to watch i just watched all the
action
I scream it yeah
[ __ ]
yeah I'm sitting close it's funny too
because that five kills Isis only ten
the music gets all intense
oh my god gentleman [ __ ] that out I
[ __ ] it up i right jumped in the
grenade I was trying to hand cannon
oh I suppose I'm sorry oh good
ah [ __ ] I should have had that
you're [ __ ] the holster nade
what is he gonna be going
well you [ __ ] jerk
I can crack good game good game peaks
although I will say that that was
[ __ ] at the beginning where
everybody's in the middle no let's just
do some quick play now I'll do one more
let's do one more
no it's fine as long as you're both in
the middle it's possible but it just one
is in the middle so much different that
it's gray wins this one oh man that
sounds like there might be a third
mathematician [ __ ] yeah dude it [ __ ] on
my radar Pikachu runs in the middle
that's where all the oh now that Koch
was once Koch was there then it's fair
as long as they like we're both from the
middle okay hi dad
I'll bet inside it I don't know music no
it's all good I'm just saying it it
[ __ ] am i Raider because I see two
spots there and I don't know if it's
yours yeah no gotcha man
clash
defeat your enemies yep let us know when
you're set all right yeah actions we can
move right yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
thinks I'm gonna take gray on this one
ladies got a better long red shot
is using visual it's all goddamn grabbed
on oh yeah I might switch it up
depending actually think that vigilance
makes more sense because yeah I was
switching off it's all good good kill
ooh
I was playing to pass him I should have
come at you the dance move oh how did
you kill me with your melee head wait I
don't understand I told me with your
melee all right I'll start I'll still
show him moves when his mom gets here
I'm ready I almost had you [ __ ] if I
don't ran into the shield
okay Wow
he's hanging outside proof
Oh run them down in the back
what now she just wanted us to show my
son moves
we'll call him as well I'm guessing sexy
moves right piece kind of does she want
oh [ __ ] that's seriously okay my god I
didn't mean to kill I didn't mean oh I
gotta kill - okay yeah did we get it
what happened there well you kill that
we have to reset
that's a reset no no no no or I just
can't go just kill me
yeah yeah just go coke yeah that's fine
that's fair yeah my bad cuz we did our
supers they're not yeah what how did
that not hit you that was [ __ ] a
little roblem that was [ __ ] a little
buggy but why aren't you running or out
cuz you died yeah 50 seconds guys just
an angry coach
yeah oh [ __ ] dude this is this is it
right here
29 seconds you're gonna bet over here oh
hey that's you
oh [ __ ]
add initial spawn or back that's there's
a long range yeah obviously I think
that's what I think we got a pic ooh I
think we got a pic shores of time or or
burning Shawn let's do burning track
yeah yeah
to serve the time might be to just to
[ __ ] yeah 60 long yeah he runs on
hard [ __ ] he was so pissed he's still
not talking
fun oh he might he might have had to get
off cuz his brother
[Music]
[ __ ]
now he's talking about his brother holy
[ __ ] mind games oh no his brother goes
to sleep so he might have had to get up
brother showing him some sexy sexy news
let's price I think Stevie's girl who's
taller Stevie's girl or Pikachu I don't
know okay I think Pikachu left a chat or
something is my buddy he won that first
game very well he's still he's still
good in that second I'm going set up on
top of the vulture yeah and I don't a
better son
you see there's no futures down
oh [ __ ]
curious Wow game on now you tell me
that's a [ __ ] area cuz you guys are
all there I was kind of yeah I was a
sneaky play cuz I thought when you said
he wasn't moving I was rolling
yes small and agile ninja
he is not talking alright I think he is
mad about it the whole mom moves thing
now he doesn't want to talk you said
sexy moves on his mom dude well he's the
one that started that
Oh his mom actually want us to show him
sexy moves that was the deal
wake-up wasn't that the deal she said
moves I guess that's fair she didn't say
what kind but I don't think she was
talking to fencer where is this dude
mom's Craig you sick [ __ ] no can you
guys hear me yeah now we can did you
arrange it
no I broke my headset by accident oh
it's the wall I threw it and I broke oh
yeah my bad I was like trying to fix it
oh well I did get mad but yeah oh yeah
oh you switched the graviton - I see
what's up Peaks no I was using graviton
the last oh [ __ ] pissed I'm not that mad
I threw my controller and you've been it
better headset I didn't break and I
broke the hole oh well I broke the ox
yeah
I'm gonna go heats on this one I'm
probably gonna lose you're not gonna
lose have a sweetheart bro the rest of
your life
that's what bullies operate that's how
bully fabric not elastic from a bully
ah nice one oh he put down a good riff
there
I shouldn't bailed when I saw the riff
go up
LT will teach you some loose peak do you
want to learn sexy moves their defenses
fighting his hand again in two of them
sexy moves Peaks or four defensive moves
Peaks you still there
your heads up break it
pekes still around
pekes every time he gets in his head he
loses the bottle maybe told ya man I
don't know why he's not talking I think
he threw his headset again I hope he
didn't throw it at Gavin though that's
not cool Peaks yeah that's his brother
he's doing sexy moves too I hope not
shut down it she's not gonna Peaks I
knew what you're gonna do to me Wow
eager to equal people Oh Jason oh my
cousin hurry
shut up Craig I don't know why really
hey guys feel no pressure
oh my god what Hockley
one minute left one minute Marquez
[ __ ] on disaster
Oh leave a second Mike they get to an 88
it'll do the best what what's gonna
happen is you're gonna throw a trip mine
done they're gonna walk eight paces from
the trip mind when it explodes we're
gonna turn around and do like us your
move buddy
you gotta you gotta kill me oh I'm not
even running that much oh I'm just
telling them what kind of smart game I
love all right you know it though to be
fair
pika-pika one and pìkô on cuz I plead
cheap no I played cheap though that's
right all right I would play him is a
long way that time ended chance all
right
man are you done with yeah high peaks
will be judged I can't hand cannon you
did how do we switch to your cameras
when we're just judging you can wow
you're just sitting in the middle to see
us play from there okay yeah I'm just
like looking at
my last yeah I got a crash - hey Pete
Peaks you still there good game buddy
you should want just not gonna hey I'll
buy you new a body a new headset thing
how much is it winner plays for the
championship as long as I could use
heavy help well actually cook always as
good with heavy - so I know
no the was a year using the other thing
right coke not a merciless sleeper
simulant right I'll have you I did you
guys hear me folks really oh there you
are would you break because my jack I
didn't break anything
I brought them broke the cord but that's
okay what kind of headset it's not me
that send me the type huh no you're not
buying me a headset Craig you already
happen to fix my phone you broke my
phone yeah yeah I totally forgot about
that I told you to send me the bills for
all these things I know I have a lot of
thing a game picture you're so salty
right now I'm not oh my salty why'd you
keep saying it just say it three times
how am i salty how my self now my salty
good yeah shut the [ __ ] up
oh [ __ ] up is not solved oh yeah oh wait
we're supposed on the middle sorry
who's playing again
is it coke versus it's coke yeah veins
okay
[ __ ] I'm good I think my head's that's
like my job I'm not gonna use those
anymore I'm gonna go on Amazon and buy
one right now I don't think I rolled
with Eddie Bravo dude yeah we here no
I've never rolling they do that would be
dope you ready
how good do you think your jujitsu is
cook club really good your blue belt
right do you like no yeah but I bet that
I bet that kid on the street he's I
don't know could take a year he was like
a that kid on the street could have
taken you he was like a purple belt
[Applause]
welcome to Harwood this is why we does a
lot more know yeah I know I can't play
can't believe pika-pika broke his
[ __ ] bike man was stupid
clergy pick a decent outcome about the
end of the [ __ ] make it to the [ __ ] you
think this five minutes plenty of time
to fight
a new pika was losing it when he was
like [ __ ] Oh
well
I should have let Pico in that last one
how's it going who's winning could coax
one who who do you think I can't [ __ ]
get a shatter and I'm dizzy
the shots are always long and doesn't
have any sense
he's a lag switcher that's why it mean
he doesn't miss a [ __ ] shot with 180
of cams as a possible I can't
let's just follow that up
yeah as have you guys ever beat him like
just yeah we beat them in like team
matches and we have two teams but not
like haha cokes good you should see his
friends thank God
Hey I'm sorry I didn't play better
against Craig guys I'm more upset you
broke yeah Peaks which teams why just
cuz it's even me and Coker gonna go it's
not even dude that's my point
no no I'm saying speaks switch teams to
coax team so we into our one-on-one so
everybody can watch me get swept by Koch
I'm not gonna win dude if Bane can't win
coke I've already done this like four
times of code the best is when Koch gets
really angry and he wants to just do it
with me cuz it's just his only way don't
feel contribution when we play trials in
your life
well sometimes it's it's good no no no
it's it's all team shots I don't give a
[ __ ] like Craig you are the reason why
we do not not he not solely the reason
but you are one of the part of the
reason we do not go flawless I'm just
saying tonight bro I didn't have the
lowest cadiz but I'm saying it if I have
a team of people like hey are we doing
heavier no heavy what is our plan it's
up to you it's up to you I don't care
all right listen is this how you're
gonna kill me come on let's just do
happen is this a real thing do some
fighters come into the fight smelling
like [ __ ] coke wears cologne is ready to
blood okay I'm gonna get you letting you
know in the middle go in the middle go
in the middle everybody or wherever you
gonna go
I'm kidding first that was beautiful
beautiful grenade there bro
that was not people ah god I [ __ ] that
up
who's shooting peeks come on you know
I'm already gonna lose doesn't help that
you're like making even ten times worse
all right I'm gonna go to the middle
gray no worries
oh you [ __ ] [ __ ]
are you at
my side
catch me outside oh come on I'm not what
you're just about done door with a
rocket launcher your [ __ ] way out
there just chilling yeah so [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm not gonna come in there
tell you the master see ya I should have
just stayed inside and let time run out
until you had to come to me I didn't
have to come winning doesn't matter yeah
that what the [ __ ] it made it it doesn't
I would've waited he still toward the
end and oh it does you trust me yeah
this is why he wants to play heavy with
me is because he knows hey I'll take it
I know you will that's why you want to
play it like this that's fine I'll take
it cuz I know you're gonna get heavy
that's what you kill me what I at least
once so far that's true
you just waiting out there you suck
hey you're a professional that you could
kill her anymore ah this is this is how
you try hard to do it I'm not gonna push
someone hardscoping Alain with a rocky
sweaty tryhard is that what you are
but ah got three Rockets got three
[ __ ] yeah well I mean I had to I had
to get more than one cuz you're [ __ ]
sittin out there the whole time
you're gonna get the [ __ ] merciless
anyway
we do that are you scared of me
hey get me ready just talking about
ratio though won't you get three and
we're doing heavy own enough a you
[ __ ] dick damn ahead said it's broken
she is Peaks I heard when he went I do
today we all knew it it happened oh yeah
back yeah I just skin [ __ ] and I threw
my controller you know the yeah it's
time to get a wireless headset
boom it's going in hard
who's your Goldie Shea yeah he'd do it
I'm not gonna come at you like you know
I wasn't saying [ __ ] like you had a tiny
little Wayne like you shouldn't shot
that rocket but I could whatever you see
something you just shoot no never like
how did you not die there's born you
want another rocket how many [ __ ]
Rockets do you i'm not let i'm trying
not to let you get have you what do you
we think my plan is here like I want you
to get hit me the whole time like it's
stupid
no you're getting heavy rockets or say
like that so you're getting heavy
I'm I'm not using it I'm keeping it from
you at this point what do you have used
it I did but I'm using this now getting
all my girls thinking oh well [ __ ] times
almost up
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you're gonna have to
go done at the end of the match I know
but you know you could have used that
going down at any time you just waited
til the end
all right good game you know if folks
goal should have been your goal should
have been to like get all 10 kills on me
that should have been your goal damn
yeah because you're that good I got that
should be the challenge that should be
the challenge for you thank you one more
time Roque one all right do you want to
do
no heavy I don't care let's go alright
yeah why don't we do to be to let's do
to be to no no let's do to be to one did
you eat you look at how cute this oh
yeah alright no heavy
what do we I'm me a pain versus Peaks
and broke broke my fall
broke my headset I I didn't break the
headset that was you [ __ ] lis
throwing case that's the wall
editor against the wall throughout my
pillow how did you break it I don't know
it bent
I mean it's working right now I plugged
it back in put it I don't like realign
it you know we'll play again peaks and
you'll probably win me next time don't
get all salty I mean if we talk if we
think about it we're just one in one
right now well well except when you lost
me in Coke so it's technically there to
be won
about no response [ __ ]
alright paying them all about I know I
know that's probably our Peaks I even
said I'd give you the I give you the
wind because I was playing cheap did I
not say that plain cheap doesn't mean it
[ __ ] I'm trying to give you the benefit
of the doubt so you want me to say
you're worse than me then I can do that
anytime I am better than you that's a
fact
oh really well you didn't prove it
tonight yeah well I got tired and
low-energy
I'm playing don't worry about it well I
am worried because I got yeah yeah yeah
well Frank's dead okay oh yeah I was
trying to get I'm here I was trying to
get a peek right in
I'm gonna use that nature that beasts
gonna play the long game huh yeah oh
damn he's absolutely correct oh car what
the yeah Wow oh yeah yeah yeah good I
like three more kills you guys over farm
oh wait outside
I'm not Chad doesn't nothing
oh it's hurt there we go nice nice paint
oh my god Wow
whoa this hand cannon is good oh yeah
Wow
once you get the rhythm on ah [ __ ] cuz
now it's coming from behind
meaning him always the god [ __ ] that's
too many
let's do 40 no alright 40 let's what we
three code now go back on that team
Peaks I don't want you on my team you
talk at all trash eeks
go back to coke side I don't care
whatever you anybody wants okay ten
people watching us yeah thanks for
watching this guy's that's awesome
you have to see who really is the worst
of the worst fire team ever do you think
Griffin could beat Craig in a 1v1 no I
want to see that happen I want to see
that if yeah if he's good he's good with
Fusion
like after this I'm gonna go like that
song on YouTube users good getting a 50
that's right let's not look comfortable
this is so a wireless ashtray that's it
I had the table beat right now I have to
eat I'll be back and I wish actually
might be enjoying himself so much
Griffen stronger players man I love coke
like standing behind everyone and he's
kick kill stealing everything
I don't do if coke got heavy he be
merciless I can't even talk but you can
kill submachine gun thank heaven I kind
of just wish we had a cat what actually
[ __ ] threw him out and break him at
station please but just don't get the
840 s dude don't get any weird ones and
asterisk because they're [ __ ] there's
like 1500 like wires coming out of that
Delta okay so one Astros a 50 yeah if
these are probably one of the best that
I've come across
yeah I'm not sure about those but those
are like half the cost so maybe maybe
those how much in there
- 800 bucks - it yeah that's gonna be a
hard pass I might break yeah I'll send
you that the ones I got that are decent
they're like 40 bucks 30 40 bucks
you don't need to send me [ __ ] bro I
don't want your charity I just didn't
say I'd pay for it should I send you
what they are people no that's cool I
don't need your [ __ ] are you [ __ ]
yeah you [ __ ] me you [ __ ] was
killing it right now I really like this
matrix I just got to practice and maybe
I'll be that's crazy
no peaks never gonna get better
yeah oh my [ __ ] hottie in one out get
out of here nice yeah oh yeah take coke
what um what site do you use on the UM
the one that gives it more under stuff
is just a more range to hit marker or
whatever the one with the I eyesight
that's one we use yeah oh yeah there we
go
catching up catching up giggity I can't
wait to show you some moves from you
know what maybe we don't know each other
you see I'm saying this is how we're
gonna win this dude yeah see bein
there's all we got to do does folks
gonna start getting so mad at Peaks it's
gonna be great no cold we're gonna we're
not gonna lose the crew I'm sorry about
pushing each other
I'm coming don't do it in two I think
they're gonna melt off oh my god I'm
[ __ ] here ah oh it walk oh wait oh
wait
yeah Pikachu can't concentrate when he
knows we're gonna show him moves he gets
a hot and bothered
dude I said yeah it didn't work out how
they're gonna stimulus I'll you at that
[ __ ] knife dancer they buffed out a
knife it's so like that fire on it [ __ ]
me out some exploding I know but I don't
remember it being that powerful I don't
know I'm trying to get I'm trying to get
to you but artists [ __ ] yes
all right here is a vessel
damn damn yeah I can't beat them and
you're gonna fight not so I got to you
know I couldn't even look up I'm gonna
sit down now I'm coming I'm coming
yeah I'm here where are you at okay yeah
I'm coming to you they're coming through
caves I'm already [ __ ] tagged it just
a shade a little bit gold didn't walk
run run run
I don't know I huh that's all right you
ran out well that's just Pecos I think
15 because 15 years old
hey don't don't talk about my age are
you gonna leave now you're [ __ ] angry
and gonna close
she keeps oh yeah I'm out here still he
sees over he was over here he's coming
around
yep I got her back what how did you win
that you were so dead
nice there we go
what's up with your age that's a touchy
subject now I'll buy your clothes can't
talk about your clothes
yeah be quiet
[Laughter]
I'm not some Pikachu's coming can't talk
about your age your clothes I can't show
you any moves I don't know what to say
about all that but they're hurt Craig's
are to picture Craig's even help bein
out you're literally like you see he's
trying to start change band oh don't
don't let him go and go to you come on
Shawn this is what he does I tell him to
team shoot what happened pitch Pikachu
was hurt Bob don't let him don't let him
separate us dude they're just talking
[ __ ] I was there but I was tagging Pete
no you weren't
I literally saw you not a shoe Craig
when Craig's there that happens he's
behind the corner close to you but he's
not no no I'm starting
I am scoping that's what he just
admitted it
what happened Craig hey Craig
damn it don't one get in your head pain
that's what they're trying to do
oh okay oh nice nice play oh yeah I'm
coming around you
nah he he's right there he's very behind
you behind you yet I'm coming cook can't
but uh I'll good we shouldn't why is
there a timer can't we just set the
score Linda with no timer I'm King yeah
why didn't we said when I'm computer
than 240 why don't you I am confused I
thought why don't you team she let you
mate
I just don't understand I understand why
you put a timer on it ah hey Craig if
you kill me [ __ ] yet
come back
feel your dad your dad your dad your dad
[ __ ]
I think iMac is not Hotel he's just a
small child oh come on Craig what are
you doing yeah you look a well I'm not
playing like earlier killing it it'll be
all right damn Craig not even 20 kills
he sad enemies see I can't even kill
Peaks cuz they're the team shooting but
you got him nice yeah we got 20 kills
after talking a lot of smack I am sure
if anybody let their team down I'm
thinking the two peaks I'm pretty sure
you you probably got me out of everyone
I might have actually I might have
actually you probably got my cousin but
we should have done no timer on the
podium that was a deal and we like yeah
that's fine get Deeks all right
you're gonna find out all right let's go
I'll put a coke
let's go Peaks I know time one switch
side Peaks switch Peaks
alright let me put some that I'm playing
Bane when I was playing the first time
last time sad bag this for real let's
see so so we got yeah yes there anymore
that's 31 to 20 coke that's what we got
a beat we gotta get more than what you
got last game with people that's all I
want
hey what's up cool cool is now following
thanks QQ I don't know why I keep saying
free play destiny hey can I can we talk
about your age and your clothing now
peek sir that's still off-limits okay
just don't cloak I pick on everybody
fighting with everybody we mean act like
I'm only picking on you did you go to
boot camp today I [ __ ] did brought
the neighbor did a good boot camp that's
what hired Diego how did he do good I
know I mean he did good with the running
but dude it's a way to deers he was died
worse than me uh I mean he was doing
heavier weights but what are you doing
coke no no coke you're not ready you're
gonna [ __ ] lose oh yeah yeah
let's go Decker day that it even to book
how many week yeah I'm gonna get him
he's hurt my badly thing wasn't pain
wasn't with me okay no I'm not blaming
him yeah hell yeah let's go come on Bain
wake up you get it Craig the pain
honestly you just like they're not hard
father
oh yeah that guy says I don't need you
to tell me I know it was
hurt him kilt [ __ ] him up pressure kick
them out there anyway he's hiding in the
corner sorry I went around I thought you
were coming that way
well what me do you think I was coming
that way the fact I wasn't mmm
ah dude don't don't play when he plays
that stupid she'll [ __ ] don't even [ __ ]
with run away fine bye bye mine can't
get away we can bring it back I can
bring him back
oh yeah we could bring a battery check
this out yeah you ain't bring your ship
back Thank You chief Esther
dude grades yeah
Clara shouldn't say yeah I was hoping
your Pikachu ice heard coke but yeah you
ran off he's right up there and a rift
hey pick me coke all right sure yeah
hold up if Craig wasn't there we would
have gone by Craig was hiding in a
little corner I was gonna come around
I'm gonna go here I've heard them a
little bit crazy absolute oh yeah nice
there we go dude I think you need to
focus
yeah yeah did we need to focus beaks
hold on dude you get sensitive Pikachu
you talked all that [ __ ] you don't want
to get slapped
I [ __ ] that up I did you got that show
no come on come on come in got him okay
why are we standing out there they got
the high ground
don't even remember what I told you
don't bother Sheila Craig that was
terrible I [ __ ] that up I meant to
slam on the platform and I fell off hey
wait for me wait for me bro don't engage
oh yes Golden Gun yeah but it's not
gonna be worth it
[Music]
your name your name yeah
now if I did already outside what's up
yeah you did it bro you [ __ ] did it
bro
suck it Craig where did you go he's hurt
he's hurt he's hurt yeah Oh yummy I'm
coming I'm coming
oh wait now what luck it get Craig how
did that kill folks coming hey cooks
coming cooks coming careful couple well
we need Chris shame he's by himself
yeah you're right you're right I'm
scared yeah we could be them they're
Devo
a kid he's grace a week I'm gone I'm got
coke hell yeah
great was so weak though oh no wait wait
alright ok if you can challenge him do
it nom dad challenged me bro [ __ ]
[ __ ] no others too so I left okay
everything okay
inside inside inside you see yah yah bro
that's fine
bah well I just died you gotta engage
with me I like imagine you're like
private Pikachu or these are latere bro
got a cage bro where are you step it up
coming I don't know why I guess but for
me
inside Wow
hey that's my homie Hale oh that's right
I just don't get how he survived though
hey wait for me wait wait wait wait for
me no one's hurt he's hurt down I wasn't
there bro I died oh my god you guys
please be a team in forever I'm dead oh
this way go this way you follow me
follow me follow Pikachu dude great idea
peaks all right I followed you and then
I got me now
yeah I follow you for you this is my
favorite team I really think you guys
should be the team or follow I call back
for that
oh why nobody that's just too funny dude
anyways seriously
come on some boat they got him
I know I know I go arc snap oh no [ __ ]
politicians I try to try correct Craig's
on the ground I can't do [ __ ] the
funniest [ __ ] there's so much there's so
much going on all right I just spawned
I'm coming to you
book
I traded coke one second earlier you
could see slow down oh my god these
pieces of hoodies yeah I'm almost gotta
Jim what are you playing two-fifty Oh
where'd you go no no I know he got you
but I just didn't know he got around you
hey genius [ __ ] please do this every
day I don't bleed bro
I might blind it from tears of laughter
mm-hmm
here I'm coming to you all right yeah
just go away
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
Wow crank you
what the [ __ ] just happened what what I
thought I got him what the [ __ ]
I thought he was that I don't know what
just happened there I don't like this
calm they're having as much they
probably wouldn't work it's just
cracking me up
you guys seriously you gotta be a team
like Oh
[ __ ] no damage that was seriously thing
of the night that's going up on Friday
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]